so I know a lot of people well as I said
earlier they'll call you an Islamophobe
they'll call Majid who's Muslim an
Islamophobe what do you make of the meme
of Islamophobia because at one time I
feared that the government was gonna
come for our free speech so infringing
on our First Amendment but what I'm now
fearing is that we're taking it away
from ourselves by what the universities
are doing and by every debate ends in
someone being called a racist right we
know what's happened to Sam that we're
due it's not the government but it's the
use of words to disciple debate we are
doing it ourselves
you know when the Charlie Hebdo incident
happened I expected all newspapers in
the free world
all televisions the whole media to stand
in solidarity with them and republish
those cartoons to show them this is what
we do this is what we are about it's an
idea and the Islamophobia meme if you
want to first of all you know to
criticize an idea is not to be phobic
Islam is a religion it's a faith it's a
set of beliefs it's an idea it's not the
people Muslims are very diverse and many
of them disagree on many things
including the position of Muhammad
including whether Muhammad should be
drawn or not drawn criticized or not
criticized so given all of that yes
you're right it's not only the
government we shouldn't give of course
the government is lobbied by 57 men you
know nations of the Organization of
Islamic Conference and that through the
United Nations and other international
bodies is trying to make them adopt laws
that leave Islam out of the realm of
discussing ideas and criticizing ideas
but it's not only that we are doing it
to ourselves schools are doing it the
education system the press even
individual I think that some of it is
because we are scared because we think
you know we don't want to be we don't
want to be shot we don't want to be
killed which is just what they want
right they want because the fear is as
powerful if not more powerful perhaps
than then murdering somebody right
absolutely absolutely that's the whole
point of terrorism is to they want to
get what they want so this is so I would
like to promote the idea that men and
women are equal and should be equal
before the law I want to get into every
Muslim community and promote that idea
and I know it's an uphill battle but for
me to do that my life is not safe and
now for the Islamic extremists they
wanted to promote the idea among Muslim
American citizens and others that women
and men should behave in a certain way
they can take advantage of all the
freedoms that we have freedom of
religion of association of expression
and I give them that yeah why can't I do
the same why is my government not
protecting me
to promote my message which is 100%
aligned with our Constitution yeah it's
so fascinating because it's so many
levels of craziness I suppose so I think
part of the issue also is that people
get a little lost in the in the
definition of terms so could you explain
the difference between the doctrine of
Islam so sort of the religious side of
it versus what political Islam is
because I think that that split in
itself I think has many people very
confused and that's why I'm trying to
use this show to get people just to
understand the basic tenants of all this
stuff because maybe that'll remove a bit
of where everyone says this is about
bigotry and racism and things like that
okay so in the 7th century a man called
Mohammed comes with a message so man
Mohammed the message submits to one God
forget about all your other gods submits
to my God the one who spoke to me there
in that cave called a hero yes and a
bunch of people say this man is crazy
we're not going to abandon our gods and
he carries on so for the first 10 years
what he is preaching is my God requires
you to pray to fast to look after the
poor to be charitable a lot of the
things he was saying in those first 10
years would fall under what
you and I and a lot of Americans in
Europeans understand as religion you
believe in these things and maybe
something good will happen maybe
something good you know you can mobilize
one if you look after the office I mean
what's wrong with that right
that's great right right and then the
next ten years of his life he moves from
Mecca to a place called Medina and he
starts to put together a militia and he
starts to wage war small Wars that he
wins that get bigger and he starts to
conquer and conquer and of course all
that goes to his head and from then on
the second ten years of Muhammad's life
that's when political Islam comes about
in the first ten years he was saying
please reconsider think about having all
these many many gods give them up come
to my one God and would be you a choice
to do it from Medina onwards you had to
do it had to happen at the tip of a
sword and every victory strengthened him
and his followers in doing that and that
happened four centuries afterwards so a
lot of the people today who are using
Islam as a political tool to get people
to do what they want them to do
following Mohammed in this example that
is that is why Mohammed is relevant
that's why he needs to be discussed to
be drawn who was he did he really live
is this really what he said if he said
so was it really more you know moral
yeah we should discuss Mohammed the way
we discussed Hannibal Julius Caesar
you know these were warriors of the past
yeah they Alexander the Great they
established all these empires and then
now they're historical figures that's
how and can we can we do that
in 21st century America without having
armed men around me all the time without
fearing for our lives unfortunately I
know the answer is to that and by the
way a lot of people on the Left liberals
well-intentioned wonderful wealthy
liberals think that the way that they
can make Muslims as a minority feel at
home in America is by respecting the
icon and I think the best respect that
they can hate to their icon is to put
him along with all those other icons of
the past yes isn't isn't that what some
are Bill Maher refers to that as this
soft bigotry of low expectations that
somehow we have to treat these people
differently yeah I want you know I want
everyone to be treated as shitty as
everyone else treat everyone equally
crappy that would be good for me and MBO
ma is you know he's on point he's one of
those few liberals who is saying I'm not
going to make an exception for my fellow
Americans sentiment why would I
I want them to be I see them as equals
ya know what and he knows there are a
lot of Muslim Americans would laugh at
his jokes and who love him but they have
to hide that from the Islamic extremists
inside of their families and their
communities yeah so that's yeah and it's
our job to emancipate them by saying I'm
I'm not in Pakistan or Afghanistan or
Somali or Egypt I'm now in America
probably in LA and I want to laugh at
them I like his jokes yeah that's the
crazy part right this that Bill Maher
when it comes to this discussion is
really being treated like a pariah by
the regressive left and they're calling
him and Sam of course racist because of
that whole Ben Affleck thing but we've
spent so much time on that I don't want
to get into that specifically look what
they've done to Bill
I want to say why can't why doesn't Ben
Affleck play the parts of Mohammed
degrade or something like that that
would be something right he had no
problem playing a fallen angel in Dogma
which was all about Christianity yeah
but I guess it's a little a little
different in this case so one of the one
of the other things when I tweeted about
you was that a couple people said how
could you have her on she's a neocon
you're a neocon yeah are you a neocon if
somebody explains to me what a near
carnies I might decide to be a neocon or
not yeah all right so I think I think
what people are saying is that
the neo-cons they really think of the
neo-cons as the sort of George Bush
Donald Rumsfeld Dick Cheney nation
builders this idea that America can
exert its influence to nation-build and
I think they they lump you in on that
take it away
it's a position in foreign policy that
if you are going to intervene in the and
you remember right after 9/11 you know
if we go out there as the United States
of America we know we've been attacked
from Afghanistan we get into the affairs
of that country how do we leave it now
there were people who were saying we
don't just go in and destroy and get the
bad guys and get out because we leave
the situation far worse than we found it
we have a responsibility to rebuild and
it's going to cost us a lot of blood and
treasure if those are the neocons count
me in on them the fact that such a thing
is really quite murky and it takes a
long time and but I find that position
to be more noble than the position we
are in now where we're going to go and
get rid of defeat and degrade and defeat
Isis by bringing in together people who
really have never fought and have them
be defeated and offer some airpower
and just muck it up and muddle through
when the neocons were in charge if that
is president george w bush he did make
huge mistakes early on but after the
surge iraq was under control it's lived
in relative peace we didn't have to pull
out these are political positions and
this is policy and you can say what you
like about the merits of the policy but
I think it is wrong to put labels on the
foreheads of people as neo cons and this
and that it's not there are a bunch of
people who thought about what would
happen after you leave the place and and
and I still think it's more responsible
once you invade a place to stay there
until things are in order instead of
pulling out two three years into it
right and I guess that's the irony is
that you know we know in retrospect that
the Iraq war was based on faulty
logic but when when we were there it was
better than it is now and that's just a
sad reality and that doesn't mean we
should be there forever but you know we
look it's the United States we're in
this weird thing we do things people
hate us we don't do things and look
what's happening now anyway yeah so I
guess that gets to like they hate us
anyway and I guess that gets your point
about labels it's also about policy you
see if you are in and maybe I can't
blame it for people who haven't been you
know in Parliament or in Pali weren't
involved in policy every single policy
has consequences intended consequences
unintended consequences you name it so
it's all about the positions you take
around these policy issues and the
position you take around a policy issue
should not define who you are and I
think people who then start coming up
with these names of neocon this and and
take it from the policy to the person
they are wrong they're malicious and
they acting in bad faith yeah and the
part of that that particularly bothers
me is that they think if they can label
you with that or whatever the label is
that then they can extrapolate every
other idea that you think and they think
they understand every other decision
that you make which is so rarely the
case many of us believe in many
conflicting things or have liberal
values and libertarian values and so on
and that plus they also distracts the
weaknesses of their policy position so
it's all about not having to discuss the
merits and emails I don't care if my
policy positions I discussed the letter
and I know that they'll have weaknesses
and they'll have strengths but in order
to discuss the policy position the
policy proposal of the other person I
would never calling this or that it has
to be about the policy yeah well you're
you're what I would refer to as a true
liberal and willing to debate the ideas